- Hey guys, it's Gary Vaynerchuk,
and welcome to episode one of Trash Talk.
Josh, you're confused, my friend.
I'm a winner, you root for winners, dick.
(audience laughter)
- Yeah, that's true,
that's very true.
- Where I talk about
trash and the flip life
of how you take that trash,
and turn it into cash.
(upbeat music)
My favorite view in the world.
♪ I said baby ♪
AJ and I, like 13 years ago,
started this log called Trash Talk.
We had recorded one
episode, we never aired it,
and just documenting the
process of buying and flipping.
It's 7:33 in the morning right now,
we're on our way to Nutley, New Jersey.
Eight a.m. town-wide sale.
The biggest thing I look
for in garage sale game,
which is a little less
scalable than, let's say,
goin' to thrift stores
or buying things online,
and flipping them is town-wide sales.
That's where the entire town
gives permits or permission
for people to have garage sales,
and so you're able to hit 30,
40, 50, 60, 70 garage sales
in two to three hours.
Makes it much more efficient.
DRock is now accompanying me.
This is like our fifth
show together, DRock.
Trash Talk, episode
one, Nutley, New Jersey,
on our way.
Let's go see what we can find.
- [Lou] Yo.
- [Gary] Little Lou, are you there?
- [Lou] Yeah, I'm here.
- How's it look, do they look good?
- [Lou] They both look like
they're just setting up,
so there's not a lot out.
- Understood, early bird
gets the fuckin' worm.
(laughter)
I'll see you in a few
minutes, five minutes.
- [Lou] Alright, bro.
- Alright, bye.
- Bye.
(slow rock music)
- [Navigation] Head south on
River Road, toward Park Avenue.
Turn right onto Park Avenue.
- The thing about garage sale
that really turns me on
is the thrill of the hunt
because it's the place
where you can really score,
a huge box of toys for
three bucks, worth $300.
I just got three mugs.
The big thing right now is I can't really
look these things up and show you because
I gotta get more stuff.
This is the early bird kinda moment.
There's three of four right now,
but I did get these three mugs.
The WWF stuff is fresh as fuck,
and we'll see how much
it's worth in a minute.
Alright, let's go.
- [DRock] 38th Prospect Street.
- Just put it into your
phone and I'll listen.
(chuckles) Potential gold everywhere.
(rock music)
Nothing here at all,
just another waste of
seven, eight minutes,
key moments in the early game
that you don't wanna waste.
Unbelievably cold start.
That place had some stuff
and we really looked at it.
- [DRock] Like what?
- The Giants hoodie baby thing.
You could probably get $30 for that,
it's like retro, vintage.
You go to like Hipsterville in Brooklyn,
you put that on Etsy,
and put 1980s Giants baby
hoodie, clothes and people like,
(hisses).
(laughter)
There's two.
Alright, I'm feelin' good about this.
This doesn't look good.
I'll be in and out.
Oh.
Fuck.
We're losin' 'em here.
- [DRock] What?
- We're losin'.
First 30 minutes have been disastrous.
Disastrous.
Usually $400, I don't need that much.
15 bucks, 30 bucks, I don't know usually,
usually, truly, you only
need about 100 bucks.
Yeah, I'm trying to pay
less than a dollar out here
for everything.
(laughs)
I ain't tryin' to pay two dollars.
(laughter)
Shit, I can feel this is about to be bad.
(grunts)
Ice cold, ah boy.
This is not off to a good start.
This could be decent.
Looks a little too new,
but we're about to fuckin' strike.
There's striking to be done here.
(rock music)
How much for the stuffed animals?
- [Woman] 50 cents for this whole thing.
- 50 cents, good.
(laughter)
Sponge Bob, maybe?
(girl murmurs)
How much is this?
- [DRock] There's a couple
more to be found, by the way.
- Alright, stuffed animals
continue to be my score.
50 cents a pop, Dumbo Disney store.
Snuffleupagus.
(bell dings)
Bang, Olaf, what?
And this one's gonna be a beast.
The FAO Schwartz, FAO Schwartz giraffe.
No.
- No, it's not.
(laughter)
'Cause it just isn't, cause--
- [DRock] What do you mean just isn't?
- Look at the face.
(laughter)
No, look at the patches on the eyes.
It's not the one.
It does?
So it is the FAO Schwartz Geoffrey.
Really?
Let me see.
It's Geoffrey, wow it's the $30 one.
- So, we just looked up the,
the Geoffrey Giraffe, Toys
'R' Us, FAO Schwartz combo,
30 bucks, paid 50 cents.
I don't know what else
to say, after Ebay fees,
just like a quick 20 bucks.
There's a lot of people not
makin' 20 bucks an hour.
(signal blinker clicks)
And that's just one of the things.
Wait 'til I look up the Snuffleupagus.
FAO Schwartz was a very
famous toy store in New York.
Anything FAO Scwartz is always gonna hit,
at 50 cents, period, end of story.
You know themes and you know pop culture,
so much of this stuff that
I care about with nostalgia
comes from my early garage
sale days, I'm sure,
because Happy Days and Three's
Company and Reece's Pieces,
and Tony the Tiger and just
like nostalgia pop culture.
I'm just like,
I'm like one with pop culture,
which is why I was good
at garage sale-ing,
pre looking up shit on phone.
That's why I'm good at trends,
and just really, deeply,
I'm deeply entrenched in
human interests and behaviors,
and things they like and
things they react to,
and it just plays out in
so many different ways.
This guy's gonna be like,
"What the hell's goin' on?"
Yeah, U-turns are, illegal
driving is really at the core
(laughter)
of garage sale-ing.
If you're not willing to illegally drive--
- [DRock] The Jersey U-turn--
- Then you might as
well, you might as well,
not come out.
Yeah, I have a very keen
eye for which producers,
and which pop culture items.
There's som Sponge Bob
stuff that I debated,
but other than that,
I feel pretty good about
what I took and what I left.
I see it, DRock.
This guy's killin' me.
This guy, literally walking
in the middle of the road
slowed me down.
People putting up signs and shit,
I'm tryin' to just win out here.
(laughter)
- [DRock] She's trying to
direct you to the sale.
(car engine revs)
(laughter)
It's part of the culture, oh shit.
(screeches)
(light pop music)
I feel like there's something here.
- [DRock] That house is one.
- I see it.
They look like OGs, they
know what they're doin'.
- [DRock] Abigail and William.
(light pop music)
- Whoa whoa whoa whoa.
GoPro.
Thank you, my friend.
- Thank you.
- Have a good day.
- You too, now.
- I'm all about the mugs today.
This Starbucks mug, 2010,
snowflake mug.
See what's up.
- For a dollar.
Should've negotiated to 50 cents,
but wasn't in the mood.
Doesn't look good.
It sold for two bucks.
(chuckles)
Paid a dollar for a mug, it's worth two.
I wanna punch someone.
(car door slams)
We'll be supporting that 25 cent man.
I'll take cup, buddy.
(money crinkles)
One cup please.
Keep the change.
- [Boy] Alright, thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Gotta support the original
hustle, you know what I mean?
Look at the pouring skills.
The extra lemons in this bowl
is really good marketing,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Caught my eye.
Good job.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
This one looks bougie.
I tend to do bad with bougie sales.
This bougie as fuck, I don't
think I'm gonna find anything.
Have a great day.
- You too.
- Thank you.
We are ice cold and
I'm not happy about it.
What's this?
(laughter)
I got excited.
Good morning, how are you?
Good.
Have a great day.
- You too.
- So ice cold right now.
It's so ice cold Trash
Talk, I'm very upset.
At least when we content,
being ice cold is okay.
I'm like Starks, game 6, Houston.
(crowd cheers)
- [Announcer] Starks score
three, came up short.
(whistle blows)
- Okay, let's go, Lou.
Yeah, Lou, that did somethin' for me.
You know what, I'm gonna
post the Supposed To video
on Instagram.
Let's take a minute.
- [Radio Man] The trailblazer,
he's making a change here.
- Really?
You didn't know I did all this?
I post every single thing,
write every single word.
On IG and Twitter, everything.
(pop music)
Thank you so much.
You got it, Lou? This is
pretty exciting to me,
vintage Lego thing, never opened.
Oh, 2003, geez I'm gettin' old.
It's still 15 years old.
I'm excited to open this up.
This was a huge score,
I already looked it up.
Paid three, they wanted five, paid three
for these Spider Man skates, in package,
never opened as well, or opened.
Pretty excited about it.
Oh, don't worry.
(laughter)
That's so awesome of her.
Alright, let's go.
(laughter)
- [DRock] Was that the seller?
- (laughs) Yeah, she goes at
least go around the corner.
- [DRock] Don't kill me.
- So good.
So good.
Lego 4098.
25 bucks.
Give it to me, Louie.
Alright, paid two bucks for this.
Alright, cool.
I really hope you picked up on her voice.
- [DRock] I do too.
Look left.
- This one has huge potential.
The wind's comin' out, I
like what I'm seein' here.
Big bear, clothes, there's
some stuff goin' on here.
(background chatter)
The size of it.
Apples to Apples is the best.
- [DRock] It's a great game.
Pikachu, Pikachu.
Cute guy (laughs).
Alright.
Got Pikachu, Pokemon, put
it in the bank all day.
Pokemon always flips,
demand is real.
(door shuts)
I say some Macy's snow globes in there,
and they are better
than I think I thought.
- [DRock] We gonna go back and buy 'em?
- Yeah.
Would you do $10 if I bought three?
- [Woman] Yeah.
- [Gary] Okay, you have a bag?
- [Woman] I do have a bag.
- Awesome.
This is fuckin' exciting.
We just bought three
snow globes for 10 bucks,
and I'm fired up.
I'm fired up, my guy.
I'm fired up.
Feel really good now.
(laughter)
Starting to get hot.
Gettin' some stuff now,
well over $200 range, maybe
a little bit more even.
Feelin' much better.
A whole lot when you need it.
I like, it's probably more, we'll see.
Let's go.
(DRock murmurs)
I feel like there could
be somethin' here, or not.
Old puzzles is fun.
Thank you
(pop music)
35.
Dogs are out, bikes are out.
- Jersey.
- Alright, now the world's wakin' up.
Whoa.
Now that is how I like, oh!
See another one over here.
Let's get, let's get, oh!
(laughter)
That third one was amazing.
The third one looks like a zoo.
Alright, now that I made 100
bucks on those snow globes,
I'm seein' all sorts of sales back there.
I'm fired up.
It's the weirdest thing ever. (laughs)
- Followed you from your original--
- Wine stuff?
- No, your original call to--
- The Cold Call?
- The Gary name was dying.
- Oh yes. (laughs)
On Twitter.
What's up Gary?
My name's Gary,
and I don't know if you've heard,
but our name is in trouble.
- [DRock] Two, three.
It says $2, would you
take a dollar for this?
- [Woman] Sure.
- Thanks.
Alright, picked up this
scary bear for a dollar,
called FurReal, from Tiger, 2004.
Let's see what it's worth.
20 bucks all day.
- Big score.
- All day, 20 bucks.
(laughter)
- It shocked you.
- Who me? Could I get more
excited about this than like--
- Than anything.
- [Gary] I like the car wash hustle.
- [DRock] I love car washes.
- I don't know.
- Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna go real quick.
Like 13 seconds.
(rock music)
- How you doin'?
- Good.
Fuck.
Out that way.
Get an angle, oh.
- Hi, how do you doin'?
- Hi, good bro.
Just picked up two jerseys
for two bucks a piece.
Kevin Durant, Seattle Supersonics jersey,
pretty rare.
Two bucks.
Garnett, really nice one actually,
stitched Celtics.
Two bucks each, we'll see.
64 bucks for the Durant.
(laughs) I mean.
- Paid two dollars.
- Paid two bucks,
you saw my, there's a little
bit of like shitty stains
on it, I can clean that off.
Just crazy.
How much are your stuffed animals?
- [Girl] What?
How much are the stuffed animals?
- [Girl] 50 cents.
- Okay, oh baby.
Two Disney scores, 50 cents each.
Have a good day.
Stuffed animals all fuckin' day.
Trash Talk, what's up?
Paid 50 cents each.
Frozen, Ann-inspired, Belle,
Disney authenticated.
This is a Build-a-Bear, Anna.
Again, you wanna look for
the Disney store stuff.
That stuff kills, just
look them both up on Ebay.
This is $17 all day,
this is $12 without
the dress, call it $20.
Trash Talk, I'm talkin'
about 37 bucks for a dollar.
Just all day.
Six.
- [Man] Are you a collector?
- [Gary] I'm gonna, for
the kid, see what he likes.
- Oh okay, alright.
- Yeah.
Take care.
Say, never a collector.
You're never a collector.
Couple minutes ago, I knew
nothing about Cherish Bears.
Now I'm a Cherish Bears expert.
Huge score, paid $20 for the whole lot.
Got about 14, 30, 30 regular
bears in this sand set.
I'm gonna look this up, it's
gonna be a crazy, unbelievable.
Yeah, so cool, right?
(laughter)
- Yeah, I love it.
- So cool, it's the best.
- [DRock] How long you've been doing it?
- I've been doin' it for like four years.
- [DRock] Okay.
- I love it.
- It's so fun, right?
- Oh my god, I could buy
a broach for 25 cents,
and sell it for $100.
- On Etsy, on eBay, on what?
- I do eBay, I do Mercari.
- Yeah, Mercari's really hot.
- It's really hot right now.
Are you? (laughs)
- Yeah, we'll use, well
yeah, might as well.
- Yeah, it's great.
- Good for you.
- Great.
- Good luck.
Keep doin' it.
I'm super mad at that lady
'cause she took half the stash.
'Cause this coulda been huge.
So I love her for her hustle,
but I'm mad that she was
there hundredth of a second.
Two dudes that took selfies with me,
they were there, they came
back after I looked it up.
Cherish Bear, motherfuckers, Cherish Bear.
(blows lips)
If if was really doing this,
I'd make, I'd make $1,000 a week, easy.
And if you, on just Saturday,
just working Saturday.
- [DRock] Yeah, I get that.
- So, ugh.
I mean, I genuinely think,
Goodwill, eBay, buying bulk
on eBay, selling on Amazon,
I just think this is the
$100,000 a year thing
for so many people making
$30,000 to $60,000 a year.
If they, just like a passion, love,
you saw how much she loved it, that woman.
We gotta show her, that's
the key to Trash Talk,
the passion.
I feel phenomenal.
This is the big final score,
this is about 100 bucks, minimum.
And now I know about Cherish teddies.
Now I'm a Cherish teddies player.
And every time, you become more
of a player of a new thing.
Look, this is very simple,
spent $40, $50, $20,
40 bucks, 50 bucks easily now
into the $500 or $600 range of resale.
I just wish so many of you would do this.
It's $400, $500, 600 bucks every weekend.
It's now 11:47, so we're four hours in.
Little gas money, I get it,
but like, nettin' that $200,
$300, 400 bucks every weekend.
And if you don't wanna be tedious,
'cause now you gotta post and all this,
cool, just throw up this,
huge collection of
Cherish Teddies, 80 bucks.
Boom, quick little, 60 bucks here.
Shit adds up when you got
groceries, when you got bills,
when you got college loans,
when you got rent.
People sittin' around dwelling.
85%, 90% of this country
working minimum wages,
low incomes, it just matters
teaching people how to fish.
Flip life, it's real.
("Ohhh Lord" by Nate Rose)
♪ You say oh lord ♪
♪ Carpe diem, it's about
time that they see ♪
♪ How many days that I been seizin' ♪
♪ And right now I'm like ♪
♪ I'm like my momma always
told me just to go for it ♪
♪ Every time they see me they say ♪
♪ Oh lord ♪ ♪ And it is what it is ♪
♪ So why you so mad at lad ♪
♪ Why there so many rappers ♪
♪ That they all started callin' me ♪
♪ They callin' me that ♪